hi this is woman Allen at the World
Economic Forum in Davos 2009 on a young
global leader at the world economic war
but also see you know the one world
enterprises agenda management
consultancy to emerging markets I
principally Africa outside United States
I just attended an awesome summit on
Africa and I wanted to make one
recommendation to the World Economic
Forum that in light a tremendous
investment present China has developed
miss developing in Africa I wanted to
suggest that in 2010 or perhaps at one
of the regional conferences this year
that there could be an event that would
bring together business leaders from
Africa and China to dialogue